centroamérica es la región del
continente en donde la comunidad lgbt
más cuenta con menos derechos como
actores civiles en panamá las personas
del mismo sexo no pueden casarse y no
pueden adoptar al no poder establecer su
estado civil como pareja no pueden
realizar una declaración de impuestos
conjunta o acceder a un préstamo de
vivienda como matrimonio ahora de que la
corte suprema de justicia saque de la
gaveta la opinión consultiva de costa
rica y es para más del matrimonio civil
porque todos los ciudadanos tenemos los
mismos derechos
según registros de la oea panamá
introdujo la despenalización de la
homosexualidad tan solo hasta 2008 el
salvador aprobó su primer derecho para
la comunidad en 2010 y costa rica creó
legislaciones a favor del colectivo
apenas hace 8 años atrás en 2014 pues
como avances de los sectores sociales el
gerente en américa latina podemos
encontrar realmente una lista muy
variable que cada uno de los países ha
ido adoptando países como colombia el
matrimonio igualitario y la adopción por
ejemplo ya son una realidad pero en
lugares como ecuador o perú siguen
siendo discusiones muy importantes para
los sectores sociales el eje
en nicaragua no existe ninguna ley que
defienda los derechos de diversidad
sexual y en marzo de este año el
congreso de guatemala votó a favor de
una ley que prohíbe el matrimonio
homosexual y eleva la pena de prisión
por aborto según reportes de la
organización sin violencia el fbi entre
2014 y 2020 3500 99 personas fueron
asesinadas por su género en américa
latina y el caribe